♪.
>> OUR ENTIRE NATION SAW
HORRIFYING IMAGES THAT DO NOT
REFLECT WHO WE ARE.
WE KNOW THAT THOSE IMAGES
PAINFULLY CONJURED UP THE WORST
ELEMENTS OF OUR NATION'S ON
GOING BATTLE AGAINST SYSTEMIC
RACISM.
JOEY: THAT WAS DHS SECRETARY
ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS LAST YEAR, A
YEAR AGO PUSHING THE NARRATIVE
THAT THOSE PHOTOS SHOW BORDER
AGENTS WHIPPING HAITIAN
MIGRANTS.
THOSE CLAIMS WERE QUICKLY
DEBUNKED, TURNS OUT MAYORKAS
KNEW THE TRUTH THE WHOLE TIME.
2 1/2 HOURS BEFORE WALKING OUT
TO THE PODIUM, GIVING YOU THOSE
WORDS, HE WAS COPIED ON AN EMAIL
ALERTED THE PHOTOGRAPHER BEHIND
THESE IMAGES DEPICTING BORDER
PATROL AGENTS ON HORSEBACK TOLD
KTSM THINGS ARE NOT EXACTLY WHAT
THEY SEEM.
HE SAID HE AND HIS COLLEAGUES
NEVER SAW AGENTS WHIPPING
ANYONE.
HERE TO DISCUSS THIS IS
"DAILY CALLER" FIELD REPORTER
JORGE VENTURA.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
THANKS FOR COMING ON ABOUT THIS.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> YOU KNOW, JOEY, I WAS THERE
THAT DAY.
THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE OF ANY
WHIPPING.
I EVEN INTERVIEWED A MEXICAN
PHOTOGRAPHER ON THE MEXICAN SIDE
DURING THE DAY ON THAT INCIDENT.
ACCORDING TO THAT MEXICAN
PHOTOGRAPHER SAID HE NEVER SAW
ANY WHIPPING OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT.
THE BIG THING JOEY, WHEN I SPOKE
WITH THE BORDER PATROL, THEY
FELT IT WAS A GUT PUNCH, ONE
AGENT MENTIONED TO ME.
THE ADMINISTRATION NEVER HAD THE
THEIR BACK AND BORDER PATROL
AGENTS WERE SOMEHOW THE ENEMY
AND WHITE SUPREMACISTS WHEN
MAJORITY OF BORDER PATROL AGENTS
ARE HISPANICS.
JOEY: EXACTLY YOU'VE BEEN TO THE
BORDER MANY TIMES.
ELISE STEFANIK, REPUBLICAN
CONFERENCE CHAIR, NEW YORK
REPRESENTATIVE, PUT OUT THE
STATEMENT TO FOX DIGITAL.
THE FACT HE KNEW IT WAS A
BLATANT LIE AND SMEARED BORDER
PATROL OFFICERS, YET STOOD NEXT
TO THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AND ALLOWED THIS
CHARACTER ASSASSINATION TO
HAPPEN, SHAME ON THE MEDIA,
SHAME ON THE ADMINISTRATION, AND
SECRETARY MAYORKAS SHOULD
ABSOLUTELY RESIGN.
THOSE ARE HER WORDS.
DO YOU FEEL LIKE SECRETARY
MAYORKAS PURPOSEFULLY MISLED
FOLKS WHEN HE GOT OUT THERE,
BASICALLY SPOKED AND CONDEMNED
THIS KNOWING THERE WAS EVIDENCE
TO THE CONTRARY?
>> OWE, ABSOLUTELY'S SPECIALLY
MAYORKAS KNEW THE TRUTH
REGARDING THE E-MAILS.
LET'S REMEMBER, FOLKS, AROUND
THIS TIME WHEN THE MAYBE HAITIAN
MIGRATION, BORDER PATROL MORALE
IS LOWEST AS IT CAN BE.
ONE AGENT MENTIONED TO ME THE
HUGE GUT PUNCH OF THE MEDIA
ATTACKED THE BORDER PATROL, THE
MAJORITY OF OUTLETS ATTACKED
BORDER PATROL, THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE OF WHIPPING.
THEY HAVE NOT COME OUT WITH
RETRACT SHUNS.
THEY KEPT THE ATTACK A WHOLE
YEAR, A TRUE GUT PUNCH TO THEM.
THEY HAVE BEEN SUFFERING DURING
THE WHOLE BORDER CRISIS.
IT HASN'T STOPPED TO THIS DAY.
JOEY: MOST AMERICANS KNOW THE
BORDER IS A DANGEROUS PLACE.
YOU KNOW FIRST-HAND A YEAR AGO
TODAY, NOT TODAY, OVER A YEAR
AGO YOU HAD AN ENCOUNTER THAT
WAS A CLOSE CALL FOR YOUR OWN
LIFE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>>
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
ON THE PHONE.
JOEY: TELL US WHAT HAPPENED
THERE.
>> JOEY, VERY INTERESTING ABOUT
THAT SPOT WE WERE IN A YUMA,
ARIZONA, BECOMING EXTREMELY
POPULAR CROSSING POINT FOR
MIGRANTS, NOT ALL OVER THE
WORLD, CENTRAL, SOUTH AMERICA,
WHAT MADE IT UNIQUE THIS HUMAN
SMUGGLER WAS TAKING CASH
PAYMENTS THERE IN PERSON BUT
REALLY IN THE MIDDLE OF BETWEEN
THE U.S. AND MEXICO BORDER WHICH
WE'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
AS SOON AS ARMED HUMAN SMUGGLER
SAW WE WERE FILMING HIM HE
THREATENED ME, THREATENED TO
TAKE AWAY MY PHONE AND SHOOT ME.
MY MIND WENT TO FLIGHT OR LIFE.
SHOWS REALITY OF THE BORDER.
HOW BRAZEN ARMED HUMAN SMUGGLERS
DON'T FEEL THREATEN JOURNALIST
ON THE AMERICAN SIDE.
THAT LITTLE INCIDENT HAPPENS
EVERY SINGLE DAY ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
WE HAPPENED TO CAPTURE THAT
MOMENT ON CAMERA.
I SAW MY LIFE FLASH BEFORE MY
EYES RIGHT THERE, BUT I WAS
HAPPY TO GET OUT OF THE MOMENT,
TO LIVE TO TELL THE STORY.
I THINK AMERICANS GOT TO SEE THE
REALITY OF THE BORDER.
JOEY: THAT VIDEO SHOWS THE
VIOLENCE AT BORDER.
THE BRAVERY OF YOU AND THOSE
LIKE YOU AT BORDER TELLING THE
TRUTH.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS NOT SO
KEEN LETTING THE TRUTH OF THE
BORDER COME OUT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOINING US.
THANKS FOR TELLING YOUR STORY.
I'M